hi there uh my name is steve kaufman i'm
the co-founder of link
and uh i'm a person who is now learning
uh my 19th and 20th language
and this is the first in a series of 12
videos as part of what we call at link a
90 day challenge or what i would call
a three month
three months to break through in
language learning i'm going to share
with you what i do how i use link
how i study languages
i should point out
that in 2005
i wrote a book called the way of the
linguist and i'll leave a link to it in
the description box
which talked about how i had learned my
first nine languages that's 14 years ago
since that time
i have learned quite a few more
languages
and i have the impression that i'm
learning languages faster now than ever
my most recent languages are arabic and
farsi
which i'm trying to learn at the same
time so my 90 days over the next 90 days
is going to be in two languages arabic
and farsi i am sure most of you who are
joining with me and with other link
members in this 90-day challenge are
only doing one language but the methods
the way we learn is the same and that's
what i'm going to share with you this is
my workstation or at least one of my
workstations i have my computer
i have
you know my ipod nano because whatever i
study on link i download the audio to a
playlist which i can take to the gym
i have my ipad
which is my favorite workstation because
it's more comfortable
than working at the computer and i'm
going to show you how i do those things
i have some goals for farsi and for
arabic for arabic i have these books in
arabic i find it very difficult to read
arabic
i much prefer to read the arabic with
the help of link where i can look up
words where i can hear the words
pronounced where i can save them to a
database where i can review them and
read again and listen again all of this
makes it
possible for me to access arabic and
improve in arabic so that eventually i
want to be able to read the books that's
an error
in farsi
i have this course from asimil a
well-known french publisher of language
learning systems they promise that if
you go through this whole book
you will be what they call b2 which is
essentially fluent i don't believe them
but i do want to get to a point
through the next
uh 90 days where i basically know most
of what's in this book i know from
experience that it won't
take me to fluency and i think that's
the main point i want to leave with you
here on my first of what will be 12
videos
in order to achieve a breakthrough you
have to put concentrated effort into the
language essentially do something every
day which is easy enough to do as i will
explain it's easy to find the time to do
it
and you may achieve a breakthrough and
the breakthrough is
that you start to feel confident
just as i said that i now feel that i'm
learning two very difficult languages
farsi and arabic faster than ever before
i will explain why i think this is what
it is about our link system today that
is much better than it was say five
years ago
and when you have this feeling that
you're doing well that you're making
progress that in a way is the
breakthrough breakthrough because that
keeps you going you aren't going to
achieve fluency in three months just as
i know that if i learn everything in the
ass email book for farsi
that's not going to make me fun
uh same with arabic even if i am able to
read the book i will be still reading
with difficulty but what i want to
achieve is a sense of breakthrough and
in order to do that we want to really
work very hard to concentrate during
this 90-day challenge period so i'm
going to be joining you joining you in
this journey
and you will be getting
more of these videos as we proceed
through our 90 day challenge
good luck to you
and i hope you all achieve a
breakthrough